my shopping guide to getting the finest
fish when I buy my fish only want the
freshest and the best and if anyone
knows how to get the best is Roger Ken
Bob he's been buying and selling fish at
the world-famous Billingsgate market in
London for over 50 years I love it I
think it's the greatest food of all time
I so literally every variety there is I
could feed you a different fish 365 days
a year
this guy really knows how to sniff out
the good from the bad
Oh fish smell different the longer it's
around the more fishy it will smell when
it's lovely and fresh it doesn't smell
whenever you're going to buy fish don't
be fine get your nose right into it then
go like they get it into it smelly
smells delightful
it smells like I called salmon E and
it's lovely for a Monday so lovely fish
the way to tell good fish is look at it
closely it's shiny it's still got the
blue monic its eyes are bright as yours
look in the girl love Ian red put it in
a bag for the gentleman please people
should always be asking about their fish
what kind of fish is it where's it come
from a nice salmon 19 bound it's a
bargain at 20 pound Rogers right that
one's brilliant value and a great
all-rounder really healthy and super
delicious here's a quick look at the
different cuts and how to use them
whole salmon always impresses it's
fantastic stuffed and steamed either in
a fish kettle or in the oven wrapped in
foil steaks are great value and
brilliant baked a side of salmon is
perfect for poaching home curing or
bacon in pastry the fill it is so
versatile easy faster cook and great for
pan frying smoked salmon delicious
cooked or raw I love it with scrambled
eggs broadly there's white fish and this
oily fish they come under two different
sections here we have white fish it's
lovely it's cold it's the best car in
the world it comes to a place called
Peter head it's nice and white the
whites of the better one of the most all
official fine mate well there it is
lovely color with most fish the fresher
they are the harder they are if you're
not well you're ill have a Macbook
sprats otherwise known as top axe here
we have flat fish and these are known as
place as you can see they've got spots
the redder they are the fresher they are
it really is a lovely fish story King
George couldn't have better for fish
fresh enough for royalty follow your
fish mongers advice and you'll never
ever have another dodgy Dover sole again
finally Fred saved the best until last
the course of the pinnacle is the
truffle they are really really so
answered this one